I just got the coke from the Busboys why
America already sort of right on the
nose I can't do any I'm very gently so I
will do coke oh nice
just come on just do some cocaine Jesus
Ricky sorry I did a little bit of it
Jess
it wouldn't mean so much to me if we
could do a little bit of cocaine
all right everybody if you have a
special request from a Caucasian name
[Applause]
come on through the drinks boys girls
get up there we won the talent show
freshman year with this little routine
you might want to stand back
no physically get back with us
shake your patty don't stop don't miss
just do it
[Music]
[Applause]
you're doing
[Music]
these are my new frames
[Applause]
[Music]
you fell you're supposed to pick up the
keys from the neighbor let me put
something on oh come on in very funny
really I love it Oh Chantal hi thank you
okay what brings you to Miami business
pleasure the business of pleasure Oh
Bachelorette weekend jess is getting
married congratulations
this marriage will it be open you know
we haven't discussed it but probably
closed yeah tightly tightly closed
mm-hmm
well we're gonna try to keep it down
yeah well we'll try not to
[Laughter]
okay before we go we got to do human
friends beat yeah what is a human friend
paid it's a photo we always take that's
like the movie human centipede where
they're sewn together mouth to bum but
it's with France so it's special not be
appropriate guys if I don't post a ton
of pictures from this weekend it's gonna
look suspicious like we killed someone
okay I can't believe I'm saying this but
I think we should do the human friend to
be okay I get the middle oh why do you
want the middle oh my god are you okay
I'm good I'm really good you sure cuz
you you landed right on your neck yeah I
just see the sort of strike shot landed
on the next step and we're back up how
are you alive right now
I don't know but I'll take it
this is it your bachelor
what's in my head there's gonna be so
many hot Miami babes we're gonna be
swimming and dead girls hi Alice
Peter hi and get out of here she's mine
now
yeah I'm getting too much trouble up
there yeah I won't get to see each other
a lot because we're all so busy with our
lives - what do you do for work these
days well sing a song Roger is the dream
potty clown is the reality but this
weekend's all about us just like old
times just got coke from The busboy why
so everyone's an animal stop being a
stupid [__] [__] until the [__]
cocaine sorry I did a little bit of it
[Music]
means let's get to the bait Mike it feel
special and then will publicly let's get
rid of all the drugs
it sounds like doing them okay so my
tell me what to do and I will do it
my uncle's a lawyer should call him
first so this was an accident
thank God please don't touch the body
what okay so actually we have already
moved here that could be up to 15 years
in prison
oh my god
[Music]
just by a little bit
right flam or hi baby boy sleep now
oh no no no
[Music]
okay before we go we got to do human
friends be yeah what is a human friend -
paid
it's a photo we always take that's like
the movie Human Centipede where they're
sewn together mouth to anus but it's
with friends so it's special
I get the middle oh why do you want the
middle this is it your bachelorette
weekend you've been dreaming about this
moment it's the first day of freshman
year we're gonna be swimming and dick
girl just got cook from The busboy like
so everyone's in I was kind of hoping
that we could make it an early night
it doesn't feel right yeah I don't think
so baby girl
[Music]
[Applause]
put all these [__] sashes oh my god
I'm so hot baby got you so now you got
too much me
male or female doubt ma'am I think email
for her fine
[Music]
no no no who's gonna do what you wanna
do I know you get the picture you gonna
do which one you're totally [__] my
picture there was this guy in Australia
who cooked his girlfriend and ate her I
can't cuz I in Vegas bye
[Music]
let's get Stella the best weekend of our
parking lot I probably have HPV now
whenever we all have each V V I don't
have HPV if you've had sex after the
1991 then you do have HPV oh then I have
like a [__] ton of HPV clumps and clumps
of it
[Music]
I don't want to go to these stupid
parties they're just one half you guys
someday our kids are gonna be together
[Music]
like pony tail right now hey
yeah we're not your words go go get out
of here I called the room next to Jett
you're gonna have to share with Pippa
who dad if I'm my Australian friends
semester abroad
this weekend's all about us just like
old times
what's next really fast
how are you alive right now okay
[Music]
[Applause]
I know that things are crazy right now
but you're gonna have a lot of material
for my wedding features
I had this nightmare where we had all
killed a guy what No
oh my god jet lag is insane you guys
it's no joke Lord joke
[Music]
you